when they start trying to break up my
>> Oh, how in the world do you bench your spine like this?
>> I don't revel in it. I don't like doing it. I don't
want to be in lawsuits. I don't want to be suing
Ian. And my favorite hobby is spending hundreds of thousands
of dollars on lawyers. >> Like, I'm sorry. What do you
What do I need to do to prove to you that this guy is just a
disgusting liar? What the are we doing here, dog?
So it for real right now
>> it is official.
I am being sued by Ethan Klene in the courts of Calgary, Alberta
for defamation.
I do plan on fighting against this, but for now it is in the
hands of the courts and our attorneys. And now all of a sudden
I'm hearing about H3 suing Idubbbz for defamation. So obviously
I wanted to hear more about that. And after diving in, hitting
that cannonball into the pool, I learned he has a lot of active
lawsuits. I think it's five, maybe six against other streamers
and YouTubers. It It's a bit of a rampage he's been on. I knew
about one before all this, which was against the Snark community
that I did hear about, and that one made a lot of sense to me,
actually. But when I was learning about these other ones, I man,
Ethan Klein has become like the Nintendo of YouTubers. He is
extraordinarily ligious. And I think it is a terrible example
for other creators in the space to follow where if they take
from this that maybe the way to fight battles online is to go
the latigious route, well then it's just a huge mess across the
board. I think it is just a very bad precedent. It's just not
something I want to see become common place. >> Without
further ado, this is Ethan Klein responding to the initial Most
Critical video. I don't know if he actually responds to the newest
Most Critical video or if he adds any context from that where
Most Critical goes further and says, "I actually disagree with
even more of Ethan Klein's lawsuits." But hey, we'll get into
it. We'll react. We'll see what's going on. >> Let's check
it out. >> Let's talk about MC Moist Critical who now dropped
a second video about um >> That was actually pretty good.
>> Thank you. Uh, he dropped a second video about my ongoing
lawsuit with I do
and um I mean straight off the bat I'll just say that I mean
I I found him to be reasonable and thoughtful about it. I mean
I'm I'm not pressed about it at all. I think he was fair. It's
nice he reached out to me
or no. So he re I'm not on Twitter so he reached out to someone
I know and then I reached out to him. But anyway, we ended up
we actually ended up talking about
>> Wait. So, thank you, Most Critical, for reaching out.
Well, actually, I reached out to him, but you know, thank you,
Moist Critical, for reaching out >> uh a fair bit.
>> And he um agreed to read a statement I wrote, which
was which I thought was all nice and fair. So, I really And by
the way, people are entitled to disagree with me. Like, I know
when when I started going down these roads that a lot of people
would disagree with me.
Um, and that's that's totally fine. I'm not mad cuz he doesn't
agree with with what I'm doing. Um,
so but what's interesting is
he his first video was very much like well so anyway, he put
out his first video which was essentially disagreeing with with
the sentiment of my lawsuit, but but also he was kind of on >> Ian
for being a giant [__] for >> He didn't agree
with the sentiment of your lawsuit. He he basically said, "I
understand you feel wronged, but I disagree with your lawsuit."
That's not that's not true. Well, he he agreed with the sentiment
of my lawsuit. Oh, I I agree that you you know, somebody sending
you skulls or something would be crazy. That's that's what he
said. He didn't say, "Oh, well, I agree with you filing a lawsuit
because of this." He actually explicitly disagreed with that.
You are just lying.
You're just lying, man. Come on. And again, this is the whole
thing. It's like you're responsible for your reaction to your
emotions. Nobody feels bad or nobody questions that if you get
CPS called on you and you feel like it's totally unjustified
that you would be upset about that and look for some sort of
retribution. Nobody questions that. It's about whether or not
you took the appropriate avenues, whether or not you're cutting
against some principles you've previously held, whether or not
you're hurting the space that you're in. These are all the questions
we ask. Nobody is mad at you because you feel wronged for having
CPS called on you over a stupid joke you told, right? That you
didn't even stand behind, that you corrected later. Nobody thinks
it's wrong for you to be upset about that.
Your reaction matters though >> for doing what he did.
Very much like
the lawsuit. Oh, it's just OTK content. Never mind. >> You
know, he >> never mind. >> He wasn't picking a side,
let's say, right? And so our fans were very reasonable about
it. I saw everybody was like, that's fair. He was being fair,
you know? No, I didn't see really any toxicity or anything. People
were generally like pretty chill with it.
But you can imagine
Hassan and people like that on Twitter, the Snarkver verse that
infest Twitter and Reddit were in they were enraged
that he didn't
completely uh >> dude are we real and people like that
on
>> The Snarkver verse.
>> The Snarkver verse. We got a whole Snarkver verse now
apparently.
I've never I've never heard about this. I've never seen this.
Excited to be a part of this narc. Okay.
Excited to be a part of it. Except for
I don't want to be attached to like some I do disavow like certain
things that happened to Ethan. Obviously, I h I disavow like
any real life interaction. I disavow anything that could threaten
real life interaction. Disagree with all that stuff. Have done
since the very beginning. Right. So, I don't I don't mind the
idea of well, the Snarkverse. I don't mind the idea of being
a part of it, but I don't want it to be used to paint me as if
some like somebody sorry to paint me as somebody who's like,
"Oh, you should have sent skulls to Ethan or you should have
called CPS." No, I don't think that. I don't think most people
do. And that's how I think they're trying to paint it, right?
And it's like, come on. No, come on. That infest Twitter and
Reddit were in they were
that he didn't
completely on me. I mean, he definitely disagrees with me. He
made that pretty clear, right? But it wasn't
to just disagree.
They were
That's why I think it's bad optics to jump on that term. Big
creators will continue to spin that word. Make a new word. Nope.
Wrong.
Wrong. Wrong. Wrong.
That is running from something. That is giving people like some
idea that you did something wrong. The second you fall back from
something, everybody who every bad faith actor will paint it
as you did something wrong. And that's why you're falling back
from it. Nope. Nope. You stand on this. You keep pointing out
that Ethan Klein is trying to paint Stark as something that's
evil, something he wouldn't participate in, but he has participated
in it for a long time. He is a snarker. He's one of the biggest
snarkers on the internet. He is full of [__] You
do not you do not step back from that. He is trying to paint
it in a way that makes it evil, but he participated in that exact
same thing. He's been in every Stark subreddit for every person
he's ever disliked forever.
He does not get to go, "Well, actually, this is snark and now
it's like about hurting people in real life." Nope. Wrong. You're
lying and you'll lose.
Uh complete feelalty.
And um
so then he made another video today kind of responding to that.
So I'll go over the broad strokes of these and give my thoughts
on it. So let's start with the first one which was called H3
verse I dub is a lawsuit suit
and I mean to on I listen it's easy for me to admit that that's
a juicer. I mean after all these years H3 suing Idubbbz was on
no one's bingo card. That's a pretty spicy little twist in internet
lore, right? I mean so
not surprised that that people want to talk about it. Um, people
don't want to talk about it though. People quite literally do
not want to talk about this at all. Most people who approach
this topic go, "Whoa, this is getting crazy. I want nothing to
do with it." Actually, that's what Idubbbz tried to do. Idubbbz
himself went, "Whoa, it's getting way too crazy. This is son
Ethan thing. It's getting way too crazy. I want nothing to do
with this." You pulled him in anyway. He actually wasn't going
to say anything. That was his version of friendship was I think
Ethan, you're pushing too far. I think you're going too hard,
but I'm not going to say anything cuz I don't want to undercut
you cuz you're my friend.
And you you couldn't accept that. That wasn't enough for you.
>> Everybody weigh in on it. So, he says first he learned
about my lawsuit for and the snark.
Charlie says he learned about all my lawsuits and he thinks the
snark lawsuit is valid.
Let's see what he says real fast here. I'm just going to go this
one. They're all >> He thinks it's valid for the wrong
reasons. That's the problem is he thinks it's valid because he
attributes things that you can't attribute to them effectively
at all. You have no basis for attributing these attacks. The
the skull sent to your house, the call the CPS. You have no basis
for attributing these to snark.
He he buys that immediately. He gives you that and he says, "Well,
I agree with suing those people." There's no proof that you're
suing those people at all. >> Pretty long video, so I'm
just going to
go through the main points here. I'm hearing about H3 suing Idubbbz
for defamation. So obviously I wanted to hear more about that.
And after diving in hitting that cannonball into the pool, I
learned he has thinks it's valid because he feels victimized
and bullied. Very Trumpesque.
Yeah. Well, he I mean Yeah. He feels victimized and bullied.
Yeah. Exactly. Right. Right.
That's
I I understand why he's upset, why he feels victimized, why he
feels bullied. It's just not the way to run
anything. It's just not You can't run your life off of your emotions
like
right? Like you might feel really angry at somebody. You want
to do something
You I
That's the thing that separates like good people from bad people
is good people feel their emotions, they think about them, they
master them, they control them, and then they move on with their
life as if like they still have to keep living in the world.
People who are bad people just get very very like reactionary.
They react to their emotions. They overreact to their emotions
and they do bad [__]
>> Lawsuits. I think it's five maybe six against other
streamers and YouTubers.
So it's >> Well, so currently I have the one against Denims
and the one against Idubbbz and the one against Noah. So three,
but two of them were resolved >> It It's a bit of a rampage
he's been on. I knew about one before all this. >> That's
fair. Definitely been on a >> against the snark community
that I did hear about and that one made a lot of sense to me
actually. >> So this part I just the problem I think is
that when trying to explain this to somebody who's not watched
like me talk about this hours ad nauseium. It's really hard to
understand all the we've been through with all these people cuz
when he says the snark one is valid, the snark one is basically
tied to the denims one. So >> that's um that's my first
thought. It's not exactly a snark lawsuit. It's part of the denims,
right? >> Essentially, yes. It's it's comp it's tied to
the denims lawsuit. Yeah. >> Now, that should tell you
a lot of what you need to know. Okay. I'm sorry. That should
tell you immediately a lot of what you need to know is well we
had to sue Denims to go after these people. I don't even know
if that's true, but like yeah, it's like you probably just can't
get anonymous internet commenters for saying Zach's ugly. I'm
sorry. I know you want to sue these people for saying Zach's
ugly, which is like from what I saw one of the biggest wrongs
that these people did actually.
But you you probably can't. There's probably just no re no reason
or no way to go after them
But um
again, I I'm I'm not going to begrudge him for not knowing all
the ins and outs of all this that we've been dealing with because
it's like it's >> been years at this point of layers and
layers of it. It's literally impossible
>> unless you've watched like every video
>> for hours. And it's it's hard to even fathom the amount
of that that these people have put us through and the amount
of steps
and things between like how we got to where we're at now. >> It's
really not intuitive. And and if you haven't been through it,
>> I here's the thing. You can't explain it to anybody.
Ethan, there's been the kilo video exists. It's right there.
It explains exactly why you're wrong. I've not seen a response
from Ethan Klein to the video. I've not seen a response from
anybody adjacent to Ethan Klein to the video. The video has gone
unresponded to because it can't be responded to because you are
in the wrong.
You haven't even attempted to respond to it. It's almost like
it it's easy to think like maybe I'm overreacting or uh
>> you know, devoid of any context. Well, he has context,
but I feel like there's just there's too much context to convey.
>> The snark community from what I recall was doing some
diabolical like harassing, stalking stuff, sending CPS. I remember
remember that in like human. >> Yeah. And I mean, so
>> Denims is responsible for that part in my opinion. She's
the one that she's the one that broadcast the whole CPS thing
to begin with, right? And then Idubbbz also was respon he said
it was cool and great and he loved it and he found >> he
said the him and Noah were talking about how
>> said it was cool and great and he loved it. Hold on.
Hold on. >> Diabolical like >> did he There's no
way he just
sending CPS. I remember remember that like human. >> Yeah.
And I mean so
Denims is responsible for that part in my opinion. She's
No. No. Wait. Did he just do it again? Did he just do it again?
WAIT, DID HE JUST WALK BACK HIS PREVIOUS APOLOGY? ETHAN, you
you had a cease AND ASSIST. YOU WALKED BACK SAYING DENIMS was
responsible for CPS. You idiot. What the are you talking about?
He just DID IT AGAIN. I DON'T THINK YOU go to another CN. I think
you could file a lawsuit at this point.
I I I hope she doesn't cuz it's probably just a waste of time.
This guy can infinitely defend himself anyway. But what the
what the man?
This is what I'm talking about. He gets so emotional. He cannot
control himself at all. Right. And he does dumb like this.
Honest to God, he just shouldn't be he shouldn't even be live
if he's this disregulated
cuz he's it's so obvious, man. You've already you've already
apologized for saying this. You know that she you can't say she's
responsible for it and now you've done it again.
>> The one that she's the one that broadcast the whole
CPS thing to begin with, right? >> She's the one who broadcast
the whole CPS thing to begin with. No, you
lying
She broadcast a bad empanada video that is mostly quotes from
you.
And then her chat had a very similar reaction to your chat, which
is gross. This guy's talking about his kids walking around eating.
That's gross. You are just lying.
Stop lying. Again, I don't understand why everybody acts like
it's so difficult to go, well, actually that video probably didn't
get CPS called on you. Like, like maybe it contributed in some
way, but it's mostly quotes from you. Maybe a little narrativization
from bad empanada, but like you told that story, right? You cannot
blame somebody for watching that.
You cannot blame them for CPS being called on you. chief blame
goes to you for telling the story in the first place, right?
And then after that, it's like
uh after that, we still don't know about the maid. We still don't
know who did it. I don't know if there's been a criminal investigation
into that false report, right? Or if it even could be determined
to be a false report.
It's just it's brutal to me that he keeps lying about this over
and over again. And oh, the other thing about it is the way you
convince everybody Denims was at fault was by doctoring evidence.
That's how you could That's how you convince everybody Denims
was at fault was you made it seem like her whole chat was saying
call CPS all the time
less than 7% of the chat ever said a message that had anything
to do with your kids or CPS or anything.
And then Idubbbz also was respon he said it was cool and great
and he loved it and he found >> he said >> he did
not say it was cool. Another lie. We covered this yesterday.
Idubbbz said that you should take responsibility for the things
you said and not talk about your kids on the stream. He never
once said you deserved it. It was cool. It was great. It was
awesome. You had CPS called on you. He's never said that. That's
never been said. Come on, man. Ian, after Ian says the accusation
is up, Charlie agrees. Then questions why Ian would share it
then. Well, that's a great that's a great uh thought there.
>> Um Charles, I love that. I just I love the idea of this
>> [__] dog [__] content being
broadcast. It's so bad and it's so stupid. It's just so weird.
>> I
again the more Moisty Critical looks into this stuff, the more
he's going to realize Ethan is basically lying about everything.
Yes. I think Ethan should basically just go, "Oh, thank you,
Moyes. I'm so I need to back off." Right. I he should be so thankful
to Moist Critical for giving him the charity that he's given
him already. And I don't know if that's going to I don't I very
much doubt it's going to continue. Okay. The Canadian laws. I
don't know. I honestly don't know. Um I think Idubbbz has
it seems like there's no way you would be able to lose this logically
to me, but I also don't know what the laws are. >> Um Charlie
and Charlie obviously was like the is this >> which I don't
know how else you can really react to it >> on screen because
I think V tubing as a dragon with a message on screen says Ethan
Maliss.
>> What a dragon because it's a big bold accusation. It's
very agree with what's being said. Dad, I'm sorry. >> No
World Cup penguin. Canadians don't like the World Cup. Okay.
Canadians aren't fans.
So big criticism of me is that in this video in which he overlays
this message for the entire thing, which was like one or two
hours, significant amount of time, he says at the he at some
point >> we're all getting couchy ads these days. It's
okay. Okay. So, I do want to say I don't agree with what's being
said in this um comment here. >> That's good. So, he doesn't
agree, but >> uh but I I'm putting it on screen because
I think it should be addressed because it's a big bold accusation.
It's very up. >> It is very up.
>> and it's despicable that he would think it's a good
idea to post that there while knowingly aware that it's not >> Also,
I don't know if Charlie knows, but like following CPS coming
to our house at 8 a.m. um forcing an investigation of our home
against our will, interviewing our children against our will.
And these are people with the actual power to take our children
away from this is not like like I don't know if people understand
the gravity of CPS coming to the house, right? And you have to
understand Ian was is part of the same group. He applauds. He
cruises in. He shouts out. He compliments these these smart groups
that you know you on one hand say it's okay that we're going
after their house, >> And you have to understand
>> Ian
was is part of the same group. He applauds. He cruises in. He
shouts out. He compliments these these snark groups that you
know
>> what what are the compliments? He cruises. He shouts
out where when what?
Bro, you've you've attached like 85 disperate groups together
that have like very little relation to each other, if any. Like
I Dude, it's crazy how hard this is lining up between Ethan Klein
and Destiny.
And I I've said this to Destiny like a million times. Ethan Klein
needs to hear this. There is no conspiracy. When you are universally
off-putting, when you are weird to so many people, when you are
annoying and and gross to so many people, they can all find you
annoying and gross and weird for different reasons with no coordination.
It's not it's not something that requires coordination. All of
these different groups can dislike you for the same reason, for
different reasons. They don't have to coordinate on why they
dislike you. You could just be uniquely gross and annoying to
most people. He has he has Idubbbz one friend that he just uses
his ammo. I don't even know what that is. I don't know who that
is. I just don't I I think it's funny that the implication I
get from Ethan very often is like Idubbbz is in the Stark left
discord. That's like the implication I get from Ethan all the
time. Idubbbz is in that Discord. Idubbbz is chilling in that
Discord. I feel like he's borderline Senate at some
It's just not true. you on one hand say it's okay that we're
going after them and I appreciate that concession and again I'm
I'm not I'm really not I just think what it's just impossible
to convey all this context. I don't think he's come to the wrong
conclusion with everything he has at his fingertips and I think
his conclusion is totally reasonable. I'm just trying to try
to fill in the blanks a little bit um in case there's anybody
who doesn't know the whole uh my whole rationale here.
>> Message isn't Ian's. This comes from Destiny and he
found the screenshot and >> Yeah. So basically yeah Destiny
said it not items. But here's the thing.
Destiny said this in a chat in a fleeting moment and immediately
>> I believe Destiny said it three times. I believe Destiny
implied that Ethan Klein was a three times at least. At least
three times in a fleeting moment. He said it he said it once
and then he said it was like a joke. No, he didn't. >> Words.
He's made it clear that I haven't been able to find the comment,
but I' i've seen it. I've showed it to my lawyer. But he says
something to the effect of um he was talking about someone else
and he said oh well that person's actually a pedo unlike Ethan.
He just the point is is that he wasn't really put out. >> Hold
on. So he didn't even disavow the statement. He was like this
guy's actually unlike Ethan Klein. And it's like an aside of
a different
allegation. He said unlike Ethan Klein and Ethan is like yes
thank you. Thank you. That's a That's a disabel. He said I'm
not a
Sorry. Somebody sent me this. It said try to defend. >> Everything
has to tie back to me. And Hassan has had a lot of success in
trying to tie people back to me. Like I said, I think this is
why I call Ethan all the time his kids or whatever is because
Ethan gave in because he's a spineless hack to this type of attack
where he's like, "No, I'm not like
But what what So Snark took this and turned it into a whole Snark
talking point. They put it all over the subre. They put it all
over Twitter. They made it like their banner. And then Ian being
a a uh >> by the way, yeah, hold on. This is clearly a
harmless joke. Tehe Idubbbz, however, it's like, dude, how could
you possibly say Desi didn't say this seriously? And then when
Idubbbz has said in the same stream that he doesn't take it seriously,
that he he doesn't believe it. You're going to go, "No, no, no.
This is all in Idubbbz. Idubbbz was definitely he meant it for
sure." Like honestly, you're going to start losing people who
would have even been on your side. you're going to start seeming
like a totally
like a just an obvious liar to even people who loved you, people
who glazed you, man. You're going to look like the the biggest
liar on earth. An active member of that community decided it
would be a good idea to further broadcast it on his entire live
stream on overlay. So he does the entire broadcast with it overlaid.
So So first of all, Destiny said it in like a Discord in a passing
moment. >> So it wasn't on stream. >> No, he it's
typed. He typed it on a Discord. It was on screen for like I
don't know floating by, right? So Ian took this comment and then
put it on the screen for two hours.
Um Destiny's comment was never meant to be taken seriously. And
although
Ian
I mean the comment on the stream that we just watched that sounded
like it was it sounded like he was calling you a because he was
mad at you. I don't know why you could say that Idubbbz is trying
to get it taken seriously when he doesn't say he believes it.
Right.
The entire point of this, which Moist Critical agrees with, everybody
agrees with, the only thing
he's trying to do is make it so that you can't react to his without
addressing that comment. His whole point is you're too much of
a to go after Destiny, so you go after everybody else. That's
the whole point.
And by the way, I will say Ethan did go after Destiny the one
time. That's why he's a [__] now, right? Because
Destiny slapped him. Destiny made him his [__] Ethan
Klein was made into Destiny's. So when Ethan Klein says, "Well,
no, I made a video about him and I I went hard on him." No, you
didn't. You actually it all up. You actually are a terrible storyteller.
You're actually terrible at the job you're supposed to do. You
actually it up horribly.
And then apparently you're calling this guy when you've got the
Pedrol account and a bunch of weird comments over a decade.
What are we doing, man? >> And starts by saying, "I don't
believe it." He also hedges it by saying, "But I also think it's
a heavy accusation that's worth reacting to." Now, if he if he
didn't believe it and it was outrageous, why would I need to
respond to it? >> Also, if you I mean, it's a stream a
live stream. People click in and out all the time. If you're
joining after he said that, you don't know that he doesn't agree
with it >> because he doesn't agree that Destiny meant
it.
Obviously, since Destiny tripled down on it, calling you it multiple
times on his stream in the chat. Then I truly do >> keep
going >> that
Snark's and by his and his intention is to cause harm to my family.
I mean there's really no other way knowing that CPS came to our
house already and that was one of the big reasons for our initial
fallout that like going on your main platform and broadcasting
this on your screen for 2 hours straight as an overlay. I of
he meant to cause harm to my family.
>> Would anybody be surprised if CPS came again? Like he
couldn't feain outrage at that, right? I mean, that wouldn't
be shocking compared to they they came the first time uh when
somebody anonymously called them and just said that there was
dogs all over the house and my kids were crawling around and
eating it. Just total silly nonsense, right? So, um yeah. So,
on one hand, he does say he doesn't believe that at the beginning,
but it's like a sliver of a super long broadcast.
Um, and also he very much hedges his
his statement with a lot of uh cheeky
doubt. Like, well, although I don't believe it, I will say it
really is worth responding to.
So, that's
you're just you're just assad like you're you're quite literally
just assad. That is all this is. I don't know how else to explain
it, man.
Like, you you know he's not saying it. You know he's not saying
that. Seriously, you know, he's not it's not cheeky. It's not
doubt. It is just saying you should respond to this. The entire
point which Moist Critical is easily able to identify is that
he's saying you're a you won't go after this guy cuz he's scary.
It's not about protecting your family. By the way, nobody's pointing
out Ethan refuses to acknowledge that Destiny did say Ethan Klein
should have CPS called on him for from his massive Twitter account,
I believe. Right. Destiny did do all of the things that Idubbbz
that Ethan Klein Ethan Klein claims Idubbbz did
and he won't go after him. And then sometimes he's like, "Well,
actually, it's because this guy was my friend. He was in my house."
It's like, "Dude, that's an emotional plea. You're just trying
to tap into my emotions to get me to agree with you." No, I've
seen what happens when you get people on your side emotionally.
You just weaponize this.
actually justify your man.
>> It's kind of I feel like he's I feel like Charlie and
again I don't think he's intentionally doing this. >> Said
it on the stream. Okay. He said it on a stream at 10,000 viewers
versus Idubbbz is 150. I feel >> like he's underplaying
a little bit of of what uh what Ian did and the context of it
and how it all happened. That's my >> just because it's
hard to understand the depth of all of this without following
>> By the way, I'm not mad at Charlie and I am not attacking
him in any way. In fact, the opposite. I think he was super fair.
He listened to me. He put my statement on screen. He read it,
which he didn't have to do. He could have just put it there.
And so I thought he was as thoughtful as he could be um given,
you know, the context that he has. It's a lot. It's a lot. It's
going to take me a lot to explain all this. Critical is very
like old school YouTuber. It's like we don't sue. We don't talk
to we don't ever mention sponsors. We don't sue anybody for anything.
>> To be true back then. >> unfortunately, that was
like before we've been under attacks that we've never seen before.
>> I was having a conversation with Charlie about it and
I >> That was true when it applied to other people, but
now we're under attack.
That was true like about other people, but now like we're under
attack, so it's like way different actually.
Like guys, now now I'm the one who's who's feeling the weight
of this. And so it's like way different now. Come on, man. >> Was
trying to explain cuz he was like, you already won because everybody
online knows that he's an [__] and he's wrong. And
I'm like, that actually I've thought about this a lot. Personally,
that used to be true. It used to be that the internet would self-regulate.
>> Well, the internet is going to start self-regulating
again as we're going to break this monopoly for sure. It's basically
already shattering. >> And if somebody did something wrong,
even someone that you liked, it would be like, "Oh, heed up.
He's wrong." yada yada. But these days with these snarking communities,
uh there's no being wrong is it's not even in the it's not even
in the equation. It's about inflicting maximum damage at all
costs. And these people know that they're lying. That's part
of the play. So there is no accountability in this community.
There is none. >> No, they manipulate to any level that
they can. They'll they'll basically try anything. They also like
organized together attacks which is something we're slowly finding.
>> We're working on something. Yeah.
They're in chat room. >> Just like you said, even this
talking point of like how come he's not suing Destiny but he's
suing Ian? >> It's a snark. >> That's a snark talking
point.
>> Yeah, it is. >> They start it and then they all
spread it everywhere. >> I hate this. I hate this. Okay.
If the kilo video is all lies, respond. Point the lies out.
If all that this snark left cuz I I'm going to take it as they're
them referring to this Discord. If these are lies, point the
lies out.
Tell me what the lies are. What are we doing here? Why do you
guys just say it's lies with no like I understand the worst thing
you guys have seen from anywhere on the internet is you feel
like lies. Where are the lies from this Discord? like that that
kilo video is
meticulously worked on and put together compiled and I if you
were willing to go and look through that and say here are the
lies I would take a look at that I'd watch that on my stream
but I've not seen that from these people they're just trying
to they're taking valid criticisms valid critique and they're
dismissing it as lies with no concern for the truth at all I'm
sorry I hate to just be Spider-Man pointing at Spider-Man in
this case according to them at least But it's not it's not just
lies. It's not just lies at all. Okay. >> Yeah. They're
in chat room. >> Just like you said, even this talking
point of like, how come he's not suing Destiny, but he's suing
Ian? >> It's a snark. >> That's a snark talking point.
>> Yeah, it is. >> They start it and then they all
spread it everywhere and they bully you into addressing it. But
essentially, they're so they're kind of doing that when Charlie's
feels compelled to put out a second video cuz even even sharing
even a shred of empathy for me, even though he ultimately disagrees,
it wasn't enough. And so he goes on Twitter, he goes on Reddit,
and he sees people losing their mind, calling him this and that,
and saying he's a hack, that he's defending me, he's running
defense for me, including Hassan who went on a whole monologue
on his stream on Charlie for for that video.
>> I mean, he is defending you in parts of that video.
Like the issue is it's like he's just misinformed or he hasn't
looked into it. And so for people to say, "Well, you wouldn't
have this opinion if you looked at the facts and then he looks
into it and he changes his opinion." I that's not attacking Charlie.
That's not on Charlie. It's saying, "Hey, I don't think you've
looked into this." If you did, I I think you wouldn't have this
opinion.
That's not on Charlie. That's asking Charlie to be diligent,
which he apparently responded to. >> And you know, these
the social media is just a total cess. It's just dominated by
these voices. Um,
people like me who value my peace. I'm not even on Twitter.
Like, and you are consumed by social media, Ethan. You say you
value your peace. You're not on Twitter, but you consistently
put tweets in your Instagram stories and talk about them and
Discord logs. Ethan Klein
has officially put a story out about Lumpy Willie. That's how
far we've That's how far we've come. That's how much Ethan Klein
has jumped the shark. He is tweeting about Lumpy Willie.
Okay, that's all you need to know. That's all you need to know,
bro. Also, did Lumpy Willie like leave these communities? Cuz
I I can't imagine he's not like doing a victory lap on this >> No,
these people love it. I don't know if they love it, but they're
there. I mean, his son is there on Twitter all day, all, you
know, and they're they're just this is their this is how they
do it. Um,
again, my my take on Ian's disclaimer
is that he's doing the least possible to try to like cover his
ass legally and also putting forward like heinous the most heinous
accusation you can make about a parent and and
he did the least possible, which isn't enough, by the way. He
didn't do enough. And that's why I kind of take cross with this
whole theory that it's like um he didn't mean it. He didn't believe
it. It's like, well, then why does he think one that I need to
respond to it at all? Two, why did he put it on screen for two
hours,
and three, why didn't he put a disclaimer on the whole video?
So, because he knows how he's a streamer, right? He knows how
it works. >> Because if he puts the disclaimer there,
I do think it undercuts like weakens the ability for it to prevent
you from reacting to his stuff. >> If you have to dig if
you have if you have to dig to find that that statement, then
he didn't do enough. Charlie says the point E is trying to dwell
here, let me just respond to his main points here. hold his own
>> and it's like yeah >> now while Ethan is 100%
correct that Idubbbz says that this is a big allegation that
Ethan should be addressing he's not doing it earnestly or at
least I don't think he was it's >> is that better >> it
was better for you with Destiny no
like literally that is you're literally your rationale for Destiny
is he didn't do it earnestly it wasn't a serious allegation so
I mean either either you sue Idubbbz and you admit he's totally
correct or you don't sue Idubbbz and you just admit you've kind
of up emotionally since the CPS call happened.
But you if you sue Idubbbz, he is just correct. He has proven
totally correct. >> Well, obviously I know Ian, but but
it's he it's not what he's conveyed. He
>> Well, obviously I know Ian doesn't mean it. Well, obviously
I don't know if you should be saying that. Is your lawyer going
to like that? Obviously, I know he doesn't mean it. >> Oh,
boy. >> Wants people to think that. I know. Yes, that is
definitely
you know that he knows that it's not true, but he's saying it
anyway. >> That's what bad faith actually is. >> dude.
He's just describing the Destiny thing again. What the is wrong
with this
>> Yes, this is the actual malice that Destiny described.
Precisely. Thank you. >> He's convey He wants people to
think >> I know. Yes, that is definitely
he knows that it's not true, but he's saying it anyway. >> That's
what bad faith actually is. malicious and the standard is different
in Canada but that is what malicious means is that you know it's
not true but >> so he just got rid of his only excuse for
not going after destiny just disappeared that he can define he
can identify that this is actual malice this is the standard
in America he just lost his reason for going after Destiny or
not going after Destiny yeah I'm I'm sorry you just it up Ela
it up for you man she pointed it out you agreed
there we all understand now I don't want him to sue Destiny I
actually don't I think it people to sue Destiny 2.
I think like while I don't think it's like a chill, I do think
you'd go cease and desist, expect a retraction, and then you
would could sue after, but he doesn't want to get any involved
to Destiny at all. He doesn't want to get any any amount involved.
And that's basically items of point the whole time. >> You
put it out anyway to harm them. >> That that's what he's
doing, right? And it doesn't make it better because he know because
he knows I don't do that, which he does know I don't do that.
What makes it bad is that he knows I don't do that and put that
on the screen for two hours, right? And and does like
almost virtually zero effort to clarify that uh he doesn't actually
believe it. As close to zero as possible, right?
>> he could have he could have easily gone, I don't know
about this. He could have gone, well, I don't know about this.
I don't know if this is true. I I have no idea. That would be
way closer to zero. What he said was, "I don't think there's
any merit to this, but I do think it's a big allegation from
Destiny, and I do think it should be addressed." That's he's
just lying. Again, it's just a lot of lies on this stream over
and over
I don't know who gives him these lies. I surely he knows that
he's lying, right?
He must have some idea that he's just lying here. >> Hard
to tell. The whole segment was awful. And the point he was trying
to make was really done. But what he's trying to say is that
clip right there at the end where Destiny said this extremely
outrageous, outlandish, disgusting thing about Ethan. >> And
I do think it's so important to remember this is one chat message
on a Discord
versus two hours on screen. >> Nope,
it was not. You are just lying again.
You're just lying again. And I know you browse all this dark.
So I know you've seen all of these, Ethan. Stop lying, man. Stop
lying. Stop lying.
He's definitely seen all of them, right? Like he he browses the
snark
>> Like even >> No, no, no. He is lying. He knows
that Destiny has doubled down on this in multiple multiple places.
He knows Destiny has called for a CPS call on his kids in multiple
places or justified it in multiple places. The same way he's
tried to claim that Idubbbz did, but Idubbbz has not done that.
Every single problem that Ethan has with Idubbbz is actually
with Destiny. And he's using Idubbbz as like an effigy as a voodoo
doll trying to attack Idubbbz to hurt Destiny somehow. I don't
know why.
>> Like saying I have no smoke for Destiny is crazy. >> I
think he means no legal smoke. >> Why would I? >> We
don't have a >> Oh no. Oh no. Oh no.
Oh no. I think I think they mean like the thing that you know
would be obvious in this case.
What did you just say? What did you just say? Wait. Wait. Wait.
Wait. What? What? What did you just say?
We We can't have legal smoke for him. WHAT ARE YOU EVEN TALKING
ABOUT, TAMAR? TAMAR, WHAT ARE YOU EVEN TALKING ABOUT?
The are you talking about, dude? I I have a feeling they're going
to Oh. Uhoh. Uhoh.
>> Why would I We don't have a legal claim >> I'm
just I'm just saying I think that's what he's referring to. >> What?
How does Ela Klene perfectly lay out 10, 15 minutes ago the precise
definition of actual malice and how it gives you a claim of defamation?
It gives you something to work towards, right? How do they do
that? And then she goes, "Well, we don't have a legal claim against
destiny. How
how in the world do you bend your spine like this? How?
Those are insane
mental gymnastics, man. Next episode, Tamar's leaving. H3 showed
281. Let's go.
>> Why would I be >> Okay, I that's that's just what
I >> I mean, something needs to happen that would qualify.
>> With Destiny, it didn't happen. It's not like what Ian
did.
>> Everyone else assumes for copyright infringement and
then he wrote some dumb
joke, quote unquote joke, horrible thing in the context of us
beefing in a scrolling chat. like that would that's not enough
to sue someone over. >> He said it on his stream. Then
he said, "Your kids deserve to have CPS called on them on his
on his Twitter." I think he also said that on his stream technically.
I don't have the stream clip, but I found the tweet.
>> It's stupid.
>> The thing is that with Destiny, the context was obvious.
He was upset that we were accusing him of something and he said,
"Well, I'm going to accuse you in
>> There was context that everybody following the story
understood what the context was. So I guess well because you
were beefing it makes sense. It's totally fine. Were you not
beefing with Idubbbz? Did you not say you were going to actually
follow him around forever? You were going to chase him forever
and ruin his life. Was that not beefing? I didn't think beefing
gave you the excuse to just lie about somebody and their kids.
But hey, you could almost say Starkers were beefing with H3.
No.
>> Apparently beefing is an excuse. Okay. Also, I love
that Ela has a better understanding of why it was said and how
it was said. Okay. Amazing stuff >> him of something and
he said, "Well, I'm gonna accuse you in return."
>> There was context that everybody following the story
understood what the context was.
>> Ian is taking it out of context
and then publicly like
totally shooting it out to many new people that don't even know
how it started. >> Destiny never meant to put that claim
out there like some big giant claim. It was a chat. Dude, dude,
how how does he do this? How does he do these mental gymnastics
in this way? This is [__]
>> dude. In a scrolling discord, Ian's the one actually,
and snarkers are the one that turned it into this big giant claim,
and then they're like, why don't you sue him? >> So, so
on one hand, Ian takes the opportunity to broadcast it to the
point where it's defamation. And then by doing that, he goes,
oh yeah, well, why don't you sue Destiny?
I mean, I feel like Destiny saying it on his stream. No. Is that
not enough? Is him not calling for a CPS visit to your house,
saying it was justified? Is him not saying that you're I I just
assume at some point these things add up. But maybe they don't.
Maybe if it's Destiny, you just give him a pass cuz he's already
an [__] I don't know. Does that not just prove the
point that I believe Idubbbz was trying to make in the first
place which is Destiny for some reason? It's so ironic because
that wasn't ever a point until he put it up.
Why would I have to sue? Why would I sue Destiny? I'm suing people
for copyright infringement. It's got nothing to do with defamation.
say these atrocious abhorrent things about Ethan and for some
reason Ethan doesn't have the same anger towards Destiny as he
does someone like Idubbbz. Now I guess >> he has the order
of this crazy because they never start. Okay, you guys get it.
I think hopefully one one came after the other
yada yada. Uh Charlie shows another clip of our show pointing
out that Ethan should be going at Destiny not Ian. I find I don't
really feel the need to >> Yeah, I think we explained it
enough >> to go for that one again. And Charlie says, "Ethan
should know better than anyone how defamatory lawsuits can be
exploited by people with >> I don't want to I don't want
to do the Destiny point again. I don't want to do that, guys.
I don't want to do that >> Lots of money." I mean, here,
I'll respond to this one. >> Didn't Destiny Well, that's
what I say pretty specific is Destiny did do worse copyright
infringement on the nuke than Denims. Destiny has said far worse
things than any of the people involved about Ethan and his kids.
If Ethan was going to sue people for copyright infringement,
Destiny has said worse things about his kids. He's put it he's
put Ethan's kids at more risk than any of the other people and
he's also infringed the copyright more
So I don't understand in this whole universe Ethan has all the
tools under his laid out rationale he should sue Destiny for
copyright infringement. Should have I actually don't know the
statute of limitations. It's possible that you only have a year
to sue for that kind of thing. I don't know. We'll see. But under
all the rational he's laid out after of with everything he's
laid out obviously that would be the case. Now, I don't think
he should do that. I still don't think he should do that. But
if he actually believed what he was saying, he would have to
do that. And he won't. >> Yep. Right. >> Ethan, of
all people should be very familiar with how defamatory lawsuits
can be exploited by those with a lot of money. He was the guy
that always fought on the right side of these kind of battles.
And now in this case, I really think he's lost his way in that
regard. What he is describing here is not even what Idubbbz did.
He's talking about you can't make these comments. That's not
free speech. Destiny made the comment, man. Literally. >> I
mean, this is just a fundamental mis just gross mis not like
gross and like I mean it's a huge just misunderstanding of how
the defamation laws work. It doesn't matter that Destiny said
it. Ian is the one that brought broad rebroadcast it
way bigger without any >> dude. It's just all lies. It's
all lies. Repeated lies.
I Ian did not even rebroadcast it that much. It's all the other
people watching it now are rebroadcasting it. Like Ian didn't
even have that much reach.
Ian's not got a big stream, dog. >> Context a scrolling
text message
from someone that I don't know at all.
So yes, you can. It is defamation rebroadcast of a a defamatory.
By the way, just Destiny's offline chat statements are seen by
more eyeballs than any statement made by Idubbbz on his stream.
Just his offline chat statements, even at the lowest peak hours,
his offline chat statements get more play, more views than anything
Idubbbz does on his stream.
>> Uh claim, right, without without uh you know, hedging
it properly or I don't know, disclosing it properly.
I this >> literally and yet you're not going after him.
You've already excused him. Wrote it off as a you know he wasn't
being serious a [__] >> I also kind of failed
to see the point where it's like if I sued Destiny then it would
be okay. He would be okay with this if I was suing Destiny. >> No,
but you you are inconsistent by your own logic. So when you when
you lay out this logic and you're inconsistent with it, right?
When you say, "Well, I will sue anybody who's put my kids at
risk." And then you have Destiny who has objectively more than
any of the other people, more than Denims, more than anyone put
your kids in the line of fire
and he's infringed on the on the nuke more harshly than Denims
did. What reason do you have not to sue him? Well, obviously
you would have to sue him under your own logic. And so one of
the things you're saying at least is a lie. One of the things
you're saying is wrong. I personally believe it's the idea that
it's about your kids at all. It's not about your kids. I don't
know why you would say it's about your kids. That's not what
it is, dog. Just stop saying that. If you just if you drop the
idea that you're defending your kids entirely and just be your
real be the whole, be who you are, then I think I think at least
people can't call you a hypocrite, right? I think using your
kids as a human shield is offensive.
It's not about that. It's never been about that. >> Does
he want more or less lawsuits? I don't understand.
and are instead going after Idubbbz who was very using it to
make a very different point and even outright said he doesn't
believe it by the way. So it >> I just like and by the
way the lie about his kids and how this is all because he needs
to defend his kids is the same as the lie about copyright and
defending copyright defending the commentary community from a
big lawsuit from Sony. Right? He needs to feed some lie to his
audience that makes him the hero, that makes him the good guy.
It's not that's not the case. He's not the hero. He's not the
good guy. He's not fighting for anybody. He is just fighting
to with people who he doesn't like. That's all he's doing. Okay?
So, any positive motives you attribute to this guy, off.
No. It's like done at this point. You can't even pretend anymore.
You're totally cooked. And honestly, like at this point, I think
a lot of people are very upset with Ethan. Honestly, honest to
God, if he just dropped all the lawsuits, tried to make people
whole for what he's done wrong, I would not have any any push
at all to cover this guy anymore. Like, just make it right with
people. Just apologize. Genuinely, I don't care anymore. What?
Dude, is your ego worth this making this the rest of your life?
How How is it worth it? Like just to go after Caseyron,
like Casey Tron, Froggen, Idubbbz, three streamers who average
a 100 viewers at best
is that that's worth losing all peace for the rest of your life.
How?
How, man? All you got to do is just try to make it right. Just
be like, you know what? I overreacted. I had a Snickers now.
I'm feeling better. I'm feeling less upset. I'm I apologize.
Here's some money for your lawyer fe lawyer fees and we're all
going to go our separate ways
because the snarking won't stop. Mine would. I'd have no reason
to go after this guy other than the fact that he's just continued
to escalate in every possible way after I originally had some
empathy for him. And I I just don't understand it anymore. I
don't get it. I would love for this guy to pause, to walk back
and say, you know what, I actually probably have gone too far
and I think it would just be better to enjoy my money, enjoy
my life, and make my silly comedy show with my friends and then
we don't have to fight anymore. I'm like calling for a truce.
Has he tried? Has he tried anything like this? Hey, can we just
have a truce? Hey, can we just like not with each other anymore?
I get that there are some H3 Stark people who really hate this
guy and they would keep going after him. But I think it goes
back to a way different level. I think everything resets to a
way easier to manage level for him. I think his life gets infinitely
better the second he does it. when they start trying to break
up my family.
I told them then and I and I still
dude who's trying to break up your family, man. Like I I really
do think he misunderstands just how many people
don't avow calling CPS who don't like him and will mock him for
the use of CPS as a predicate, as a pretense to continue to go
after people, but don't think it's okay to call CPS on him. Like
like that's most people in my experience. People will laugh about
it the way you've weaponized it, but nobody actually believes
that you deserve to have your kids taken away. Well, very very
very few people. I'm sure some people I would say that and then
some people who are just committed to the online like always
over the line bit would say, "No, no, no. I uh I actually do
think you know we should call CB." Sure. But other than those
people who are just committed to like a comedy bit where they
constantly Sam hide over the limit, right? Other than those people,
nobody actually thinks that, man. Seriously. Wait, what did Kilo
say? He's already at war and taking legal action months before
CPS. Repeat it a million times. Repeat it until I die. Yeah,
I mean, he was, but I'm saying that he's talking about empathy,
right?
And yes, I know that he was planning to sue people. He was already
weaponizing like the DMCA system on Reddit long before any CPS
call was made, right? I know that. I know that. Everybody knows
that. It doesn't mean I don't have empathy for the CPS call like
and what that what he felt like that did to his family. It's
not like I can't jive with that. It's not like I don't understand
that. I can very easily understand it, right? But it wasn't what
set you off. It wasn't what made you latigious. It wasn't what
made you start to escalate. Right? You were already in the process
of escalating
over and over and over again. And just like I would say, I disavowed
those legal actions. I disavow you doing all of that. And you'll
have to make it up to people. you will have to like actually
look for absolution. Seek forgiveness from the people you've
wronged, right? It's not like an easy thing to do. I I don't
think it's possible for Ethan, in fact, at this point. But
like it it's it is theoretically possible. And again, I just
want to rehighlight that basically nobody agrees. Nobody thinks
that the CPS call is justified in any sense. Like like they might
think you you caused it. They might think that it doesn't have
anything to do with snark, but that is so far off from believing
that you deserve to have your kids taken away or deserve a CPS
call or anything like that. Okay. Geez. >> You know, >> I
warned everyone then that the rules had changed for me and there
was no limit. There was no >> the rules had changed long
before
this happened. Those that was not the impetus for the rules changing.
Ethan,
stop lying. Why do you lie like this? Why do you consistently
create clips where people can automatically go pull your fake
DMCAs, your false DMCAs? You using the DMCA system to try to
find people's personal information. You explicitly registering
your stuff with the Library of Congress before CPS was called.
Why do you continue to lie?
Stop lying.
This only gets worse the more you lie. Honest to God, if you
just tried to fight with the facts alone, you would do far better.
But you keep lying because you need to make yourself the victim
to everybody. It's sad. It's embarrassing. It's pathetic.
Stop being pathetic, man.
>> No, whatever red lines, whatever com whatever like lines
of decency or morality or everyone thought was like the norm,
like that's all been erased for me. >> You planned to violate
these norms before CPS was called. You were violating the norms
with regards to false DMCA's. Okay. With regards to weaponize
the copyright system, trying to get people's information, looking
it up, and then basically hinting at leaking it all over the
place, right? I believe you hinted at leaking it on Instagram.
I believe you've made you've basically trickled out people's
PII, threatened to dox them, right?
You didn't have red lines long before CPS was called. Stop lying.
Everyone's had enough. It's time to just be honest. Okay, it's
time to confess. I need like the the angel chorus sound. Okay.
Confess. Confess what you've done, Ethan. Confess that you never
had red lines. That you you've always been planning to escalate
in these ways and it had nothing to do with CPS. My god, man.
My god, man. With this stuff.
Like, you came after my kids. You came after my family. Oh, he
was just joking about it. He doesn't believe it.
Like there it's just I feel like I'm surprised anybody has honestly
when I filed this I was like I feel like there's no way anybody
could possibly misunderstand me or defend Ian because I mean
what he said >> it's like I mean I mean you just don't
say that. You just don't say that about someone's family or children.
Like that's just like that's the worst thing you could do or
say especially to a former friend. >> I think YouTubers
are just very sensitive to like seeing YouTubers doing
>> Yeah, dude. I it I understand. I I will even give you
I will give you that the emotional weight of somebody saying
that you like aren't the victim you pretend to be given that
they're a friend that that's higher. I'll even give you that.
I can give you that, Ethan.
But it I'm sorry. I've watched you weaponize your emotions to
convince people that you're doing the right thing over time like
repeatedly.
And you never improve. You never walk back. You never you never
try to reach any sort of understanding with other people. You
just attack. You are a crybully.
So all of these all of this emotion which I feel is real. You
are weaponizing it to create a justification for you to keep
going.
It's not real. You aren't engaging with reality. You need to
engage with >> Honestly, when I filed this, I was like,
I feel like there's no way anybody could possibly misunderstand
me or defend Ian because I mean what he said. Just >> Ian
has never said anything that put your kids at risk more than
a million other people.
You just wanted to go after him because honestly I think it's
you feel betrayed because he wouldn't stand up for you even though
he disagreed with you. You basically felt entitled to his defense
even though he disagreed with you. Right? That is the betrayal.
You thought you were entitled to him defending you no matter
what you said or did. And honest to God, he probably made the
right call. You were not a good friend. You were somebody who
just had that connection through for clout and you didn't actually
care about what he thought, what he felt. You just wanted him
to come out and defend you to be one of the guys who would come
and stand shoulder-to-shoulder with you while you did bad [__]
He probably made the right call in not defending you, right?
But regardless, it was after the CPS after the CPS call to begin
with. So, he has no culpability there. He had never said a bad
word about you before the C before the CPS call happened. You
cannot blame him for that.
But you continue to. And if you're going to say anybody justifying
or saying it was justified to call CPS on you is someone who's
a free target. Well, congratulations. You still haven't differentiated
Idubbbz and Destiny in any way. They're the same again, apparently.
Well, actually, technically, you're lying about that, too. Idubbbz
did not justify it at all, and Destiny did. But regardless, okay,
that's Destiny did that, too. Already showed it on stream. >> It's
like I mean I mean, you just don't say that. You just don't say
that about someone's family or children. Like that's just like
that's the worst. >> Unless you've already made Ethan Klein
your because he has a bullied kid. Bullied like middle school
kid physion. Okay. That's all he's ever been. And he knows that
the bigger bully is somebody he's got to kneel to and so he will
do >> thing you could do or say especially to a former
friend. >> I think YouTubers are just very sensitive to
like seeing YouTubers doing
>> Yeah. Listen, I don't want to s I listen I don't revel
in it. I don't like doing it. I don't want to be in lawsuits.
I don't want to be suing.
>> Hi there. My name is Ethan Klein and my favorite hobby
is spending hundreds of thousands of dollars on lawyers. Today
I invite you into my home to share my favorite pastime with you.
Join me in creating generational wealth for my attorney. Yeah,
listen. I don't want to sue I listen I don't revel in it. I don't
like doing it. I don't want to be in lawsuits. I don't want to
be suing
Hi there. My name is Ethan Klein and my favorite hobby is spending
hundreds of thousands of dollars on lawyers. Today I invite you
into my home to share my favorite pastime with you. Join me in
creating generational wealth for my >> Like I'm like I'm
sorry. What do you What do I need to do to prove to you that
this guy is just a disgusting liar? Like that is who he is at
his base level at in his soul. Like he Come on, man. How the
How the do you say these words? How do you go live today and
say I don't want to sue anybody? I don't I don't revel in this.
I don't enjoy it. Come on, man. What are we doing here? What
the are we doing here, dog?
E soing for real right now. Thank you for the raid. Appreciate
it, man. I don't want to do any of that [__] But
like these are people that don't self police.
These are people that >> and nobody else would police.
Like Reddit will never do anything for us even though we've tried
so much. >> I've tried everything before reaching this
point.
>> I've tried
Right. I don't want to be the latigious that's suing everybody.
Like I know what I know what people think of me. I know what
people
say about me. I don't want a video of of Charlie making a video
saying that he thinks I've lost my way and I'm doing some frivolous
spite driven lawsuit against Idol. I don't want any of that stuff
and I'm not I'm not a [__] I know >> it's like
it it is a spite driven lawsuit and it is it is frivolous even
if you say well technically I could do this in Canada man. I'm
sorry. It just >> like the consequences of doing all these
lawsuits and stuff, but at a certain point in my life after dealing
with this for so long and trying everything like there needs
to be some in my mind there needs to be accountability
for the >> No, you've not tried everything. You've only
tried attacking.
Not tried everything.
I I'm sorry. I just don't believe that. All you've ever done
is try to like force these people to bend to your will
and you think because you got a lot of money that's okay.
I'm sorry. Like that nothing's been more made more evident to
me than these people have money and they see people who don't
has money or don't Hold on. I'm going to cut this back. Hold
on one second. Nothing's been made more clear to me through this
whole thing than the fact that these people have money and they
see anyone who doesn't have money
as less than them. That's what they see, right? If you don't
have money, you are less than. Shut the up about my misspeak.
Okay?
If you don't have money, they see you as lesser than. That's
how they see you. They don't think you're the same level of person
as them.
They honestly think you should have to kneel to them because
they've got money because they could sue you. I'm sorry. I don't
want to live in a world like that. I DON'T LIKE THAT. And I Hey,
listen. I can't do very much. Okay? All I can do is point out
to everybody that you guys see yourself as better human beings
worthy of additional rights, worthy of additional privileges.
Right? You see, you see everybody else that way. And I'm just
going to point it out and I'm going to ask everybody else what
they think. Okay? I'm sitting here talking to regular people.
I'm talking to the pros. I'm talking to the plebs and I'm saying,
"You think this guy is better than you? Look at how happy this
guy was. He says he doesn't revel in the lawsuits. Look at how
happy he is talking about burning his money." >> Hi there.
My name is >> Look how psyched this guy is. >> And
my favorite hobby is spending hundreds of thousands of dollars
on
>> on lawyers to destroy people's lives. explicitly to
destroy Idubbb's life, to try to destroy Casey's life, or to
make them kneel to you, right? Cuz you should have to kneel to
me.
I'm sorry. That's not the way it works. Okay? And I say this
as somebody who I defended Ethan. I have a stream where I'm arguing
with with Quean about this like a year ago, and I'm still taking
Ethan's side and being fair to Ethan on everything. Like, I'm
I'm giving the most general I still I don't agree with them suing
people, right? But I'm still like being as generous as I can.
I'm still being as empathetic as I can be. And he has burned
it all. Every bit of empathy I had for him. I can still identify
that I was feeling empathetic that I had empathy for him. But
I've watched him weaponize any empathy I had for him so that
I would let it go when he goes and sues people, when he goes
and with people, when he goes and doxes people, when he files
false DMCAs, when he tries to get everybody's information so
that he can then menace them with it. Right. I I was not paying
enough attention. I'm paying attention now. Okay.
You're not better than anybody else, Ethan. You're not better
than any other YouTuber. You got lucky. You're not even that
funny.
Instead of counting your blessings, instead of thanking God for
everything you've been given, you've decided to become this petty
tyrant who tries to destroy anybody's life who's criticizing
him. And it's not going to work. You could sue me tomorrow. Please
don't, by the way. Please don't. you could sue me tomorrow.
It won't make you right. It won't make you more popular. It won't
change your reputation. It won't do anything to help you. It
will only hurt you. And you apparently can't stop. You can't
stop hurting yourself. You can't stop hitting yourself. You have
enough money that you can keep punching yourself in the face
until you bleed out on the floor.
And personally, I would hope that the people around you care
about you enough to prevent you from doing that. But until I
see that happen, I'm going to assume it doesn't exist. I'm going
to assume they don't care about you enough to prevent that from
There's a reason defamation exists. And by the way, Ian is not
some little peanut. He's a large creator, one of the biggest
creators that ever was on >> If Ian wanted to play by the
old school rules like YouTubers that respect each other, he would
not engage with Snark every day and post and show them on
>> you both engage with Snark constantly. Ethan was literally
scrolling and had is following the Idubbbz Snark Reddit. What
the are you talking about? What the are you saying?
>> Trishy land is a snark subreddit. Ethan has followed
every snark subreddit for every one of his enemies since the
beginning of time. He has always done it. He is the original.
He is the He is the primordial starker. Okay, it's insane. How
can you try to gaslight me like this? Why would you try to gaslight
me like this? It's It's totally nuts.
scroll snark on his stream and call them good people when those
same people sell merch with CPS and a skull on it.
>> I think what these people need to understand too is
that's not an endorsement of it. It is mocking your weaponization
of that, taking advantage of people's empathy over it to continue
to basically, you know, manufacture consent for all the devious
evil you're doing. Evil is a relative term here.
Right? Like, I'm sorry. I'm just going to have to point it back
to the October 7th analogy. Right? October 7th doesn't give you
the pretext to invade Lebanon. Sorry. No. No. Only empathy only
goes so far, man. No more. No more. No more.
And the items the items lawsuit really is the invading of Lebanon.
It's probably actually the Noah Samson lawsuit, but it's like,
dude, we we can't do this anymore. We're done. We're done with
this one.
Ela hates both of these analogies, by the way. Ela is very on
the other side of both of these analogies.
No, no, we have to we have to invade. No, we have to invade Lebanon.
We have to do it now >> because they think it's so funny
that CPS came to our house and human skulls were sent to our
house. They think it's so funny that they sell merch with it
>> and he
Ian calls them good people. He browses it on his stream. So like
all those um like moral like oh yeah we're YouTubers we have
some unwritten rules we all follow. Nobody's following it for
years now. It's all been gone.
>> That's not true. In fact YouTubers used to go after
each other. Used to say about each other. Used to talk all kinds
of
you literally were friends with Idubbbz who did content cops.
What the [__] are we saying? >> Yes. Exactly.
I I agree. the old YouTube that like we used to all have some
like mutual respect.
>> No, you didn't all have mutual respect. You guys were
just the biggest bullies on the block. So, you didn't care. >> Nobody
could go after you cuz you had all the viewers. You had all of
the manpower behind you. You were the biggest bullies. Like I
What do you think a whole bunch of the history How do you think
these Snark subreddits H3 Snark Leftovers H3? What is it? What's
the other one with Trisha Pis? What was there? Frenemies. Frenemies
2 or whatever. What do you think these snark subreddits started
because of? They started because of your actions. You offended
people. You upset people. Trust me, as somebody who's already
pissed off a lot of people in his own audience, I understand
that you could basically alienate people entirely in a way that
like at the drop of a hat. Anything client's been doing that
for a decade now. Okay. For a solid decade. And a lot of the
a lot of the complaints have
legitimate reasons they need to be made.
You ever read out those DMs between Ethan and Trisha? No, I didn't.
But we keep going. >> There are some golden standards that
you I mean that Yeah. For me, those days are long gone. And I'll
tell you those days really disappeared for me when CPS knocked
on my door at 8:00 a.m.
>> Total lie again. Uh, cut back to before false DMCA's
abusing the copyright system in what, December, January, like
long before the CPS call. registering his copyright with the
Library of Congress in January before the CPS call. He had every
intention of abusing the legal system before the CPS call. The
CPS call did not change his reason for doing this, his reason
for escalating. It did not change his rules of engagement. What
iota. Not even a little bit. He's just lying. I don't I'm not
looking to destroy their lives or get um get caught in this like
quagmire of a sick effed up lawsuit. I don't want that. I don't
want a lawsuit on my shoulders. That's all I want. just
and I said that even before the lawsuit and honestly the same
is true of Noah Samson. If he if he just issued like a heartfelt
apology I'd probably consider dropping it
just acknowledging like what you did and you're >> No,
you're wrong. You shouldn't have filed the lawsuit. You filed
a lawsuit. That's total He shouldn't have to apologize to you.
Um just just apologize to me for my for my frivolous lawsuit,
my strategic lawsuit against you know Samson and then I'll drop
it. No,
you you should apologize for filing it. You should apologize
for making everybody else like for you should apologize for suing
all these people. That's what should actually happen. Dude, I
can't believe he just said Noah Samson should apologize to me.
That's crazy in it. >> This shouldn't come as a shock to
anyone. After learning more about those other lawsuits that Ethan
is engaged in, like the fair use lawsuits and such, guess what?
I don't agree with those either. Now, obviously, I don't know
all the nitty.
Does Ethan think him saying this makes him seem magnanimous,
merciful, generous, even? I think so. I think he's like, "Oh,
I'm trying to make it better. All you have to do is apologize
to me for me suing you over something everyone basically all
the other YouTube creators agree is not something I should be
suing over."
Wow.
So, >> agree around every single lawsuit. I've >> so
magnanimous, so generous, so forgiving. Oh my god. >> Just
begun learning about all of these, but from every >> So,
tell me why you disagree. thing I've seen from the lawsuits that
he has actively going on. There's nothing in there that makes
me think that this is like the right way of doing things or that
this is different from other times in the past where creators
have sued each other over uh disputes. Now, clearly I'm >> What
is the right thing way of doing >> Except it's creators
that >> you saying these people
going after if it's about copyright going after people who have
violated your copyright and caused you more harm.
>> No longer following those unspoken rules >> don't
lie about your justifications for engaging in these lawsuits.
Like we used to respect if you're reacting to somebody, you're
not going to just steal their video, you're not going to show
the whole thing or you're not going to watch it and tell people
come watch it here and don't give the original one views. Like
you you weren't going to do all those things and now these people
that we are suing >> how how did they create those norms
and what enforced those norms and why is this different? Why
why is it different than when the Jinx guy was doing it? Right?
The black guy who would just laugh in the corner. >> Why
is it different than that? >> That they did those things.
>> I I just I wonder if you saw this clip. I do. I wonder
what he would say about this clip >> too much of a sumi
because you know >> not that one by the way I didn't mean
to pull I literally just typed >> I feel like I can smell
his breath when he open his mouth
>> many people be I'm looking for the clip of her saying
if you like that uh not having to watch his video >> yeah
we I guess he hasn't >> he probably hasn't but you know
you're Charlie captured now >> that
by the way just to be clear a court gave a tenative decision
where they said that was not dis that was not proof of anything
that was nothing
and morally although I do think It's weird that Denim's like
revels in that. I don't think it means it's not fair use. I don't
think it means that she didn't transform it. And ultimately,
that's what I care about. The fact that she gives a nod to the
people who are watching who don't want to give you any views.
I don't really care about. Yes, that's not really that big a
deal to me. I don't understand why you're trying to make it seem
like that was a part of some elaborate scheme to deprive you
of views when it clearly wasn't.
>> This is my biggest ops. By the way,
>> I don't know all the nuance and intricacies of fair
use law. Ethan would certainly know that better than I and many
others would. So maybe he has some strong cases here. And in
one of the instances with one of these streamers, it did seem
like they were just uninterrupted playing the video without even
an attempt to transform it. So maybe that could be like a easy
fair use win for Ethan. But I just don't think that's a win overall.
Like for as long as I've been on the internet, that kind we've
been having the conversation. >> Lost in general, yes,
it's it's a lose-lose situation. Nobody's happy to be in it,
>> right? I mean, they say the lawyers are the only ones
that win. That's true.
Luckily, I like my lawyer and I want his kids to be well educated
and taken care of. It's really just I just really like my lawyer.
I don't care about the lawsuits. I just want to take care of
him. Just make sure he's okay. You know, >> kind of behavior
is been frowned upon. And I really think if the targets were
different, if it wasn't streamers that a lot of people don't
like, the response would be very different to these lawsuits.
Right now, a lot of people celebrate them because they just hate
the people that Ethan is suing. So, they go yee-haw for it. But
these individuals, like the streamers in particular, for fair
use, they are a fraction of the size of Ethan. So, it's to me
a hard case to make that he was genuinely like losing eyeballs
because of them streaming it on their Twitch >> They sip
in a significant amount of views, especially denims, I would
say.
luckily for everybody involved, they didn't think that that was
a market that she had access to regularly that they didn't think
that was a market you had access to and they r they ruled it
at least at least in terms of the tenative ruling fair use.
And I would say that it seems very unlikely to me that their
justification with respect to her audience size or her comments
about whether or not you like or sorry give me a like or give
give me a sub if you liked not giving that video a view. Right?
They ruled that
not
Why would that